الحديث عن بدء الجيش الاسرائيلي مرحله
جديده من الحرب على غزه لا يعدو كونه
تغيير مسميات بالنسبه لسكان قطاع غزه فما
قبل المرحله الثالثه كما بعدها غارات وقصف
مدفعي يوقع اكثر من 120 شهيدا في اقل من
24 ساعه ورغم التصريحات الاسرائيليه عن
انتهاء العمليات في الشمال وتدمير البنى
التحتيه لكتائب القسام تشهد بيت لاهيا
وجباليا اشتباكات بين قوات الاحتلال
وفصائل المقاومه فيها تزامنت مع تحليق
مكثف للمقاتلات وطائرات الاستطلاع اما حي
الزيتون فالصور الوارده منه تشير الى
ضراوه المعارك من شارع الى اخر وفي
المنطقه الوسطى تركز قوات الاحتلال
استهدافها للمخيمات الابرز في المنطقه
المغازي والبريج ودير البلح ففي المغازي
سجل سقوط نحو 60 شهيدا في غارات جويه وفي
دير البلح اكتظ مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
بجثمان الشهداء الذين سقطوا في القصف على
المنطقه الوسطى اما في البريج فقد اعلنت
كتائب القسام ان مقاتليها تمكنوا من قنص
اربعه جنود اسرائيليين والى خانيونس التي
يؤكد وزير الدفاع والمتحدث باسم جيش
الاحتلال على اهميه المعارك الدائره فيها
فقد قالت كتائب القسام ان مقات ل دمروا
دبابت ميركافا وقصفوا تجمعات للجنود
والياته وفي بني سيلا استهدفت قوه
اسرائيليه راجله بعبوه مضاده للافراد وسقط
عناصرها بين قتيل وجريح وقد تعرضت خان
يونس بدورها لقصف اسرائيلي كثيف اسفر عن
شهداء وجرحى بينهم نازحون قصفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه
خيامهم